il frôle les 10 dollars sont bourrés de
sucre et pourtant ils font fureur auprès
des jeunes on scrute les conséquences
néfastes de la consommation des thés et
des cafés desserts
[Musique]
l'hiver les entreprises rivalisent de
créativité pour nous offrir des cafés et
des réconfortants
l'été des boissons rafraîchissantes tout
aussi gourmandes j'ai pris un beau boule
aussi jus kiwi et boule aux fraises
cappuccino glacé au caramel extra crème
fouettée de la passion café glacée
extravani est-ce que vous faites ça
souvent vous retrouvez entre amis pour
boire des thés des cafés souvent quand
il fait beau genre on sort dehors puis
comme on juste pour se retrouver
ensemble après l'école c'est comme bien
de prendre du temps un peu
est-ce que c'est la mode on dirait je
vois tout le temps des jeunes qui ont
des boissons à la main c'est quoi qui
est branché de boire ces petits poissons
là
c'est mon 4e c'est
presque pas de caféine là dedans par
contre mais c'est mon 4e
il y a une grande tendance toutes les
endroits qui essaient de vendre des
cafés sont en train de multiplier leur
offre pour pouvoir
occuper d'autres moments dans la journée
les cafés desserts les thés aromatisées
deviennent extrêmement important dans
l'arsenal de ces placés l'industrie
s'était misé encore une fois un peu
subtilement en exploitant le côté social
des adolescents avec des programmes
parfois de fidélisation beaucoup de
marketing et au bout du compte des
jeunes qui consomment trop de sucre
liquide
[Musique]
bien que ce soit très tendance ce n'est
pas d'hier que l'été et café dessert
gagnent en popularité chez les 13 à 18
ans quand 2004 et 2015 environ il y a eu
une explosion de ces produits là une
augmentation attention de
580% des ventes juste des cafés
aromatiser chez les jeunes c'est une
période de la vie où on aime faire ses
propres choix quand il est temps de
consommer on aime personnaliser son
produit
[Musique]
avec café avec café parfait est-ce qu'on
regarde la crème fouettée sur le dessus
oui avec crème
ça s'appelle dans bien des cas du café
et du thé et ça on a l'impression que
c'est pas
dangereux ou que c'est pas malsain c'est
l'ajout de plein d'autres éléments
autour qui rendent ces cafés là de
véritables desserts mes impressions
crème fouettée sirop chocolat miettes de
biscuit Moka 480 calories 24 g de gras
55 g de sucre c'est pas un café c'est un
dessert faut pas l'oublier
[Musique]
nous avons voulu savoir quelles
alternatives moins élevés en sucré en
gras les cafés Starbucks offraient à
leurs clientèle on a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue mais on nous envoie
une réponse par courriel expliquant que
l'entreprise a tenu son engagement de
réduire de 25%, le sucre ajouté dans les
boissons gourmandes en 2020 et à
introduit de nouveaux menus qui offrent
du goût sont plus faibles en sucre et
offre une personnalisation
puis quand vous commandez est-ce que
vous faites vos choix en fonction du
goût ou en fonction de ceux qui a dans
vos boissons
mais je fais jamais attention on voit
que le sucre cause déjà à cet âge-là une
certaine dépendance au niveau des
systèmes de récompense du cerveau il y a
des connexions qui se font encore et une
fois qu'on est allé stimuler trop
souvent avec ces produits sucrés là le
sang du plaisir ben on diminue les
récepteurs du plaisir puis on en veut
toujours plus et ça va rester pour la
future vie d'adulte
et il n'y a pas que sur le cerveau que
le sucre cause des dommages qu'on soit
en surpoids en situation d'obésité ou
qu'on soit même
l'effet et le même tout le monde
transforme au niveau de son foie le
sucre en gras et ce Grelet qui est caché
au fond de notre abdomen lui a des
impacts très néfastes sur l'inflammation
puis éventuellement le développement de
la maladie cardiaque chez la personne
adulte
[Musique]
même si les effets néfastes sur la santé
sont connus ça n'empêche pas les chaînes
de restauration de proposer des formats
de plus en plus grands et de créer de la
nouveauté à chaque saison
présentement les plus gros joueurs dans
la catégorie c'est les Starbucks Tim
Horton même McDonald's alors c'est sûr
que lancer des nouveaux produits
différents de leurs produits
traditionnelle ça vise à élargir leurs
clientèle et donc très souvent aller
chercher plus jeune
le prix de ces boissons peut frôler les
10 dollars ce qui n'empêche pas les
adolescents de coller au café et tes
desserts comme un aimant au frigo que
des gens qui consomment le café à tous
les jours qui veulent pas mettre un 6 ou
un 7 dollars sur une boisson quand c'est
consommé de façon événementielle c'est
une fois par semaine c'est pour me
réunir avec des amis tout d'un coup
c'est plus grave de payer 7 dollars
parce que l'économie c'est pas juste le
café c'est le café l'expérience le lieu
la rencontre le wifi et selon vous parmi
les quatre bois
sons
moi je pense que c'est parce que avec
des goûts de fruits
[Musique]
derrière l'apparence de jus de fruits
des théopales un produit un peu plus
récent sur le marché canadien se cache
une montagne de sucre on va avoir des
consommations de sucre qui vont tourner
autour de 60 à 80 parfois même dans
certains thés desserts on va aller
jusqu'à 100 g de sucre par consommation
selon vous c'est lequel que le plus de
sucre dans les quatre boissons
[Rires]
il y a du caramel aussi
voulez-vous qu'on fasse une
expérimentation
alors dans cette boisson avec crème
fouettée il y a 70 g de sucre vous
voulez voir à peu près combien ça
équivaut
est-ce que tu veux savoir dans certains
de ces boissons aux perles ça peut aller
jusqu'à 100 g alors 100 g de sucre les
copains
c'est ça
etes-vous surpris vraiment je pensais
qu'il y avait comme un cube par boisson
est-ce que ça va vous faire changer vos
habitudes et savez-vous c'est combien
qui est recommandé par jour 25
alors
non
l'effet du sucre est le même que celui
de la drogue donc on a une fausse
réassurance comme parent quand on pense
qu'ils sont en sécurité parce qu'ils
sont en train de développer une
addiction au sucre bien connue bien
documenté qui va être permanente pour le
restant de leurs jours
[Musique]